the urban skyline of Ho Chi Minh City is
witness to Viet Nam's construction boom
there are building sites all over the
city with investors from across the
globe crowding into a market that's
growing at 6% a year nobody wants to
miss out on that and Germany's no
exception a highlight of the German
prime minister's three-day visit to
Vietnam the inauguration of the
so-called deutsches house the center
that'll house German diplomats the
offices of several German companies and
perhaps also a cultural institute and
academic exchange service the signal
were sending is this Germany is making a
long-term commitment to Vietnam this
isn't only in our own interest it's also
because we want to continue supporting
Viet Nam's process of modernization and
liberalisation within the framework of
our partnership with this country at a
height of 107 meters the German house
provides a lofty perspective the hope is
it'll become a hub for German ties with
Vietnam for us the Deutsche's house is a
great symbol of the friendship when you
know different Republic Germany in
Vietnam we know our two peoples and I
would like to say that it's not the
deutsches house not German house well so
Vietnamese house after visiting the
capital Hanoi Steinmeier is now in Ho
Chi Minh City
it's his longest day yet in Vietnam the
development of this communist country
fascinates him they are here under the
exists in Vietnam the last time I was
here was eight years ago and what one
feels here in Vietnam isn't just change
its the ambition the optimism and the
dynamism especially among the younger
genomic finding in India Univ and gain
about Sean and that mentality is bearing
fruit on both sides of the Saigon River
you can see hotels bang
and company headquarters close trade
relations and economic success is also
politically irrelevant Vietnam gains
more weight in Asia for Germany this
means a more powerful partner in the
region Vietnam could now move on in
terms of civil rights this is a hope
that foreign minister Steinmeier has
quite openly spoken out here watch
Steinmeier is staying quiet about is his
political future there's talk in Berlin
he might run for German president no
comment from him on that but in either
capacity he's more than likely to keep
on visiting dynamic Vietnam